what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk about
all things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like Marvel
Studios might have already cast
officially the next Wolverine for the
MCU and yes I am talking about the
Wolverine that will be with our new
X-Men team when they finally debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and yes it
does appear like we are going to be
seeing him before his official debut
with the X-Men or his own Solo movie
According to some new reports it does
sound like he is going to debut
officially but also not officially in
Deadpool 3 and I'll explain exactly what
that means recently we have gotten
reports from several insiders that in
Deadpool 3 Deadpool is going to be going
around the Multiverse and essentially
interacting with different Wolverine
variants this is nothing new we knew
Deadpool 3 was going to be a multiversal
film we knew that Deadpool himself would
be going around jumping from Universe to
universe and we know that the TVA is
going to be on on him as well we know
Mobius from Loki is going to be
appearing in this show and of course we
know that the one and only Hugh Jackman
is returning as Wolverine and making his
MCU debut however it looks like Deadpool
is going to come across many other
variants of Wolverine possibly even
before he gets to our Wolverine Hugh
Jackman's one thing that Marvel Studios
has done a really great job with Keeping
a Secret so far is the story in
relationship between Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and Deadpool in Deadpool 3.
thank you Kevin feige Love You Kevin
feige we don't quite know why they're
going to be teaming up however one thing
that we have learned is that Deadpool is
kind of looking for the perfect
Wolverine for whatever reason for
whatever Quest that he has maybe it's to
save the Multiverse or save one specific
Universe for whatever it is we know that
he's going to need and want the help of
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine but in this
process he's going to see all of these
other Wolverines and apparently one of
these Wolverines that we come across in
Deadpool 3 is going to be the official
new Wolverine now there are a lot of
implications with this for the future of
the MCU but we do kind of know what's
going to happen up until Secret Wars and
then after Insider Casey Walsh has
stated that by the end of Deadpool 3 we
will have a very very big hint Marvel
Studios will have hinted at who the new
Wolverine is going to be meaning we're
going to see a variant and it's going to
be pretty obvious hey this is actually
the new one moving forward word that's
what Deadpool 3 is going to do now
Deadpool can break the fourth wall so if
there's a joke to be made about the new
Wolverine he's certainly going to do it
and I would imagine it's going to be
some snarky comment by Deadpool that
tells us oh hey that's the new Wolverine
that is who Marvel Studios has
officially cast so something that's
going to be insanely important in this
movie is when Deadpool starts
interacting with different Wolverine
variants so we'll have to keep a look at
when that starts happening we've also
recently heard that Daniel Radcliffe who
of course plays Harry Potter in the
Harry Potter series he has been cast in
a secret role for Deadpool 3. and a lot
of us assume that it's Wolverine a
wolverine variant there have been rumors
about Daniel Radcliffe possibly being
the new Wolverine for a very long time
now and Deadpool 3 is kind of going to
be like Multiverse of Madness but only
bigger and like Secret Wars based off of
what we've heard so far Deadpool 3
really is going to be kind of the
Multiverse of Madness that we were
expecting kind of bigger with a lot more
cameos we've heard that a lot of the
original X-Men are going to show up and
possibly the original Fantastic Four as
well which I hope is the thing because
I'd love to see Chris Evans as the Human
Torch the possibilities are endless but
according to Insider Daniel rpk Daniel
Radcliffe isn't the mcu's Wolverine now
this technically could be interpreted in
different ways for example The Insider
my time to shine hello states that the
MCU Wolverine at least until the end of
Secret Wars is going to be Hugh Jackman
So Daniel rpk could simply be stating
that Hugh Jackman is the Wolverine at
least until Secret Wars but I'm going to
take this at face value and simply
interpret it as Daniel Radcliffe isn't
the new Wolverine now Never Say Never
it's definitely not off the table
especially if you've seen him in miracle
workers going crazy and ripping his
clothes off he definitely seems like he
could play a killer Wolverine however of
course he is not the only person that
has been rumored to possibly play
Wolverine a big name thrown out there
was Taryn egerton and we know that he
has met with Marvel Studios we also know
that he he almost played an X-Men before
in the past he was offered the role of
Cyclops he confirmed this with an
interview with the real sway he said
that he didn't want to play the
character because he didn't want to play
a character whose eyes were covered the
entire time as an actor he uses his eyes
to express a lot of emotions the eyes
are a big part of acting so he said
that's the reason that he turned down
that role but Wolverine shows his eyes
even if he's wearing the headgear for
The Wolverine costume which we've heard
he is going to wear but even if he does
wear that it still shows his eyes plus
not to mention if he is going to play
the new Wolverine for the New Mutants
and X-Men teams that are coming to the
MCU then they'll most likely do an
origin story and he probably won't start
off with a costume so not really any
risk there and since he's met with
Marvel Studios plenty of times by now
Kevin feige could have said this is it
this is the role we want you to play
what do you say and maybe he's accepted
it whoever they decide to get to play
Wolverine is going to be in Deadpool 3
it sounds like which means Marvel still
videos has officially cast their
Wolverine already which is absolutely
crazy to think about however we do know
that Kevin feige thinks about 10 years
in advance he basically confirmed that
at any point in time whatever he's
currently revealed as far as the phase
slates are concerned they have about
five or six years after that plan so
thank Avenger Secret Wars he's got five
to six years planned past Secret Wars
which is going to be the X-Men so it
makes sense that they would have already
chosen who they want to be Wolverine and
start to kind of tease them in Deadpool
3. that's really clever actually however
like The Insider my time to shine hello
stated Hugh Jackman is going to be the
mcu's Wolverine until Secret Wars you
may have heard that he is coming back in
secret Wars and it is also possible that
between the King Dynasty and Secret Wars
they explore other universes in the
Multiverse that is collapsing in fact
we've heard that the new Fantastic Four
movie might actually take place in its
entirety with the exception of maybe the
end of it in another universe so that
would mean Deadpool 3 and the Fantastic
Four would be two movies in the MCU that
are taking place outside of the main MCU
timeline the main MCU universe that we
know and love and this really makes you
wonder what it's going to be like after
Secret Wars because we know the new
Fantastic Four team that is coming is
going to be our new main Fantastic Four
which means they're most likely going to
stay in our universe after Secret Wars
same thing for Deadpool we know he's
going to end up in our main universe so
this could heavily hint at what is going
to happen after Secret Wars the
Multiverse might not actually be
restored but we could be moving forward
with kind of a combined universe or a
shared Universe our main MCU moving
forward after Secret Wars could be a
collection of universes that fuse
together due to the events of Avengers
Secret Wars and all of the incursions
and whatever Kang decides to do with the
Multiverse unless Marvel Studios has
decided that moving forward after Secret
Wars they're going to cover different
universes with their movie be making
meaning one movie will be set in one
Universe maybe Earth 838 then another
Universe like our Earth 616 and another
one which could be Earth 99 literally
anything and that could be a way to go
but I think most fans would prefer
everything to kind of be taking place in
one universe that way it's all still
really connected like the MCU has always
been but go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about that in the comments down
below it does seem like they have
officially decided who their Wolverine
is who would you like to see play
Wolverine in the MCU let us know your
thoughts about that and what do you
think happens after Secret Wars does
everything combine and we now have many
universes in one what do you think about
that let us know and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway or a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month you can also find
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf